this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream curiositystream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals why not check out
apocalypse world war one draws from over
300 hours of archival footage and it
traces the journeys of civilians and
soldiers who fought for survival in one
of the darkest times in all of history
it examines an era that fundamentally
changed the worldwide balance of power
from the wars outbreak in 1914 to the
u.s intervention and ultimately the
treaty of versailles curiosity streams
available on many platforms web app
broker android xbox one smart tvs ios
chromecast amazon fire amazon apple tv
deep breath and it's available worldwide
go to curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and for you guys you
can use the code biographics and you'll
save 25 percent off which comes out as
only 14.99 a year that's 1.25 cents a
month that's super affordable anyway and
compared to other streaming services
it's super super affordable so click the
link below or go to curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics and save 25
right now
and now back to today's video
according to the fbi the moment when
lucky luciano rose the top was the
watershed events in the history of
organized crime he completely changed
and modernized the american mafia making
sure that whatever turf disputes power
grabs and other petty squabbles might
develop between different crime families
they did not get in the way at their
ultimate goal
making money
under his new system governed by the
commission any major decisions were
brought to the table and voted on by the
highest ranking mobsters by getting the
families to work together he transformed
the mafia from a bunch of gangs
constantly fighting with each other into
the most powerful crime syndicate in the
country
charles lucky luciano was born salvatore
de chenia in a small sulphur mining town
in sicily called le carrafridi his date
of birth is somewhat disputed it was
either november the 11th 1896 on
november 24 1897. his parents were
antonio lejania and rosalia caparelli
and he had four other siblings the
family emigrated to america when charles
was just a nine-year-old bambino and
they settled in new york city's lower
east side he attended public school
until he was 14 at which point he
dropped out and found a job as a clerk
with a shipping company however he
realized that there were faster and
easier ways to make money if you were
willing to break the law in fact luciano
had started a few swindles as soon as he
arrived in america he was first arrested
when he was only 10 years old for
shoplifting after that while he was
still in school he started a protection
racket for the other italian and jewish
students but allegedly it was a dice
game that convinced him that he wasn't
meant to just be another working stiff
as he walked away with over 240 in
winnings at a time when his job paid him
five dollars a week as a teenager
luciano hooked up with the five points
gang active mainly in lower manhattan
where he met many of his future
associates such as johnny torrillo vita
genovese and frank costello he mainly
handled protection rackets and some
occasional pimping and drug dealing on
the side during one momentous extortion
attempt luciano met a jewish teenager
who would later help him revolutionize
organized crime mayo lansky someone we
have already covered here at biographics
in case you want to see his side of the
story we're not sure where luciano
acquired the nickname lucky it could
have been from his good fortune at the
gambling tables or from his tendency to
avoid prison despite being arrested
numerous times it could also have been
from surviving one particularly
harrowing incident when other mobsters
beat him up severely and cut his throat
leaving him with permanent scars and
droopy eye or it could have simply been
derived from his last name as far as his
first name was concerned luciano started
going by charles instead of salvatore
because he didn't want to be called sal
or sally which she felt sounded too
feminine by the time prohibition came
around in 1920 luciano was already
working for one of the most dangerous
men in new york joe masseria aka joe the
boss who was in charge of the most
powerful gangs in the city around the
time lucky also collaborated with
another highly influential mobster
arnold the brain rothstein he acted as a
sort of mentor for luciano and taught
him how to run a criminal empire like a
successful business at the end of the
day making money was what mattered most
but lucky didn't really endear himself
to some of the old-school gangsters due
to his close association with jewish
criminals like lansky and rothstein many
of them didn't like working with
italians born outside of sicily let
alone non-italians however this
mentality only made luciano feel like
maybe it was time for some changes to
let go of the old ways and form a new
and modern criminal enterprise and those
who weren't willing to change
well they had to go too
[Music]
we've talked about this important
chapter of criminal history a few times
in our bios about bugsy siegel mayor
lansky and frank costello so we'll just
give a cliff notes version this time
basically during the late 1920s a
violent power struggle known as the
casamarezi war emerged between two new
york factions one of them led by the
aforementioned joe the boss masseria the
other by salvatore maranzano while these
two gangs were fighting to establish
themselves as the head honcho a lot of
their underlings were growing
dissatisfied with their role within the
organization many of them understood
that as long as there was a capo de
tuticappi one boss above all others
there would always be multiple people
vying for that spot which in turn meant
the gangs would be forced to fight each
other instead of doing other activities
that made them money therefore in may
1929 they held a landmark summit in
atlantic city where they discussed the
future of organized crime eventually
leading to the formation of the national
crime syndicate a loose confederation of
gangs from all over the country working
together or at the very least not
actively
working against each other everyone who
was anyone attended the conference enik
jackie johnson acted as host and
represented new jersey al capone and his
men represented chicago santa
trafficante senior represented florida
there was also the philly mob and the
detroit purple gang new york of course
had the most representatives from all
the italian crime families plus the
jewish and the irish mobs two notable
absentees were masseria and maranzano
they would never have ceded power
willingly so instead it was decided that
both of them had to take a dirt nap the
first one to go was joe the boss in a
hit that was planned by lucky luciano
himself as masori's lieutenant he
reached a secret deal with maranzano to
betray his former boss in exchange for
his rackets and a position as
marazzano's new second in command
masseria was gunned down in a restaurant
on april 15th 1931 with mobsters like
vito genovese bugsy siegel and albert
anastasia rumored to have been the
triggerman now savitor maranzano was the
new boss of bosses and though his reign
at the top only lasted for a few months
it was long enough to have an impact
most notably he organized new york's
italian gangs into the five families a
well-known structure that actually still
exists today albeit under a different
name he also developed the ranking
system within the family with a boss who
had an underboss several lieutenants
called kappa regimes and then soldiers
he even gave his organization a fancy
new name
lacosa nostra anyway by september
maranzano realized that luciano was too
ambitious and too dangerous to keep
around so he wanted him six feet under
lucky knew this so he planned his own
hit against marazzano again we don't
know who the shooters were but a
four-man squad burst into maranzano's
office on september 10th and gunned him
down several more hits were carried out
in the weeks that followed on
maranzano's associates who would not
have taken kindly to the reforms that
luciano and his colleagues had in mind
with both masseria and maranzano dead
luciano could have proclaimed himself
the new boss of bosses but he didn't
not exactly instead he and several other
mob bosses formed the commission in 1931
a sort of governing body for the
american mafia all important matters and
conflicts were brought to the table for
discussion where every boss got a vote
although the boss of the most powerful
family was always considered the de
facto leader which in this case was
obviously luciano with this new world
order established it was time for
luciano and his cohorts to concentrate
on the profitable enterprises
even while he was still working under
joe maceria luciano ran one of the most
lucrative bootlegging businesses in new
york but now as the head of his own
crime family he became involved with
gambling extortion loan sharking
prostitution drug dealing and book
making not to mention all the extra
income he gained by controlling
interests in construction companies
trucking companies garbage collectors
garment stores the docks and all other
sorts of union jobs he made vito
genovese his underboss while frank
costello served as his conseguiri
malenski also held an important position
within the commission and always had
luciano's ear but he could never attain
a rank higher than associate since he
was not a full-blooded italian alongside
guys like costello and bugsy siegel
lucky also helped form the public image
of the stereotypical mafia boss that you
see in every mob movie the one who's
always dressed in nice suits and fancy
silk shirts and went out to eat at
expensive restaurants and then went to
party in trendy nightclubs with famous
celebrities micronu enjoyed being a
public figure but this a downside
because it also garnered the wrong kind
of attention like that from prosecutor
and future governor of new york thomas
dewey dewey proclaimed lucky luciano to
be public enemy number one and made it
his new mission to bring him to justice
this was not the prosecutor's first
rodeo he had previously put bootlegger
waxy gordon behind bars and was on the
verge of doing the same to jewish
mobster dutch schultz before schultz's
murder in 1935. little did do we know at
the time he was the reason for schultz's
death and
luciano indirectly saved dewey's life
dutch schultz had wanted to kill dewey
and as per the new rules he asked
permission from the commission they
refused since killing a prosecutor would
have brought way too much heat on them
but schultz intended to ignore them and
do it anyway that was when luciano and
the other mob bosses voted to have
schultz whacked for going against the
commission now that dewey had luciano in
his sights he focused on his thriving
prostitution ring and the countless
brothels he brought in police officers
outside of the vice squad and had them
wait on the streets ready to strike only
telling them the locations of the raids
minutes in advance this was done in
order to foil any attempts to warn the
mob and the strategy paid off as dewey
made hundreds of arrests also worth
mentioning was his assistant director
attorney eunice carter one of the first
black female lawyers in new york's
history she was instrumental in building
the case against luciano by gaining the
trust of many of the prostitutes and
madams that were caught up into his
raids ultimately she got multiple women
to testify that luciano was the boss in
charge of the organization carter backed
up their statements by following the
money trail which always led back to
luciano by march dewey and carter had
built a strong enough case against
luciano that they were ready to proceed
with the arrest in late march 1936
luchano was staying at the waldorf
towers under the name charles ross when
he got a tip that detectives were on
their way up to bust him he quickly left
the hotel drove to philadelphia where he
borrowed some money in a new car then
drove to cleveland ohio where he caught
a train to hot springs arkansas a place
where he hoped he could lay low until
the heat died down luciano's plan didn't
work he was recognized and arrested in
early april prompting an extradition
battle to new york where he had been
indicted on over 60 counts of compulsory
prostitution aka pimping a few weeks
later bucky was in new york and by may
his trial had begun the case against him
was strong dewey painted an accurate
picture of luciano's influence and his
role within the mob by presenting his
connections to numerous other criminals
his numerous arrests and the testimonies
gathered by eunice carter then dewey
focused on luciano's inability to
explain the source of his wealth since
it was clear that lucky lived the lavish
lifestyle of a millionaire even though
it only declared a yearly income of 22
500 it seemed that after dozens of
arrests with no convictions luciano's
luck had finally run out on june 8 1936
he and eight co-defendants were all
found guilty on 62 counts each despite
attempted bribes threats and even
attacks on his life dewey had triumphed
and lucky luciano was sentenced to 30 to
50 years in prison
although he was now behind bars it was
all business as usual luciano still ran
his criminal empire with frank costello
and vito genovese carrying out his
orders on the outside however once he
exhausted his appeals and it became
evident that he wouldn't be getting out
anytime soon luciano ceded power to
costello and named him the new acting
boss of the family to the great
displeasure of genovese who wanted that
position for himself but
more on that later that's how life went
for the next few years until luciano saw
a new opportunity for freedom provided
to him by an unexpected source world war
ii once the united states had joined the
war there was a growing concern over
enemy spies especially after the ss
normandy a french ocean liner caught
fire in february 1942 and sank while
being refitted in the new york harbor
although the exact motive for the cap
eyes has never been established the
american government feared that it was
the work of a saboteur when their own
efforts to weed out possible spies among
new york stock workers did not yield
substantial results the government began
thinking laterally and turned to an
organization that had already been
controlling the docs for decades
the mob thus began operation underworld
a cooperative effort between the us
government and the mafia to foil
sabotage attempts prevent labor disputes
during wartime help undercover agents
and limit black market theft the first
mobster approached by naval intelligence
officers was joseph lannster a mid-level
gangster with the luciano family who ran
the fulton fish market at first the
government just wanted to help so their
agents could go undercover and keep tabs
on workers with mussolini sympathies
however lanza recommended that they ask
his boss for assistance since lucky
still controlled the docks even though
he had been in jail for six years by
that point luciano agreed to help and he
was moved to a more comfortable prison
as thanks although it is still a matter
of heavy debate whether operation
underworld was actually of any use or
not some rumors even say that the mob
were the ones who set fire to the
normandy in the first place anyway once
the war was over luciano filed an appeal
for clemency on the basis of his
cooperation thomas dewey the same man
who put him behind bars was now the
governor of new york and he actually
agreed to commute luciano's sentence in
recognition of his wartime aid although
he still got the last laugh in early
1946 after almost a decade in prison
lucky was once again a free man but his
release came with a heavy caveat he
would be deported to italy and never
allowed to return to the united states
on february 9 lucana was escorted by
immigration agents and new york police
officers to a freighter called the laura
keane malansky claims to have bribed the
guards to arrange a little farewell
party for luciano champagne food women
were brought aboard the ship as luciano
lansky costello and a few others had one
final get-together to reminisce about
the good old days according to the
police this never happened and their
account is supported by the fbi report
from an agent who was there under cover
so who knows if it actually happened or
not one thing was certain on february
the 10th lucky ducano set sail for italy
and he would never set foot on american
soil again
just because lucky couldn't physically
be in new york did not mean that he was
ready to give up his criminal empire
that he had built however italy was a
bit too far away from the action so
after his deportation he made plans to
relocate to cuba malenski already had
multiple gambling operations in the
country and the mob had pegged it as a
great new investment opportunity not
just for gambling but also for
prostitution drug dealing they would
have needed someone to stay in cuba to
look after their interests anyway so if
everything went according to plan it
could have been like luciano never left
to that end the mob scheduled another
summit like the one in atlantic city
back in 1929. this one took place in
december 1946 at the hotel nacional in
havana although getting there proved a
little problematic for luciano since he
didn't want to tip off the us government
to his whereabouts he had to leave italy
a few months earlier and make several
trips through south america to lose his
trail before he finally arrived at his
destination incognito the main talking
points at the havana conference included
the status of the drug trade and a final
decision regarding the fate of bugsy
siegel who'd gotten on everyone's bad
side after bundling the development of
the mob's first hotel in las vegas
luciano also weighed in on the rivalry
that was brewing between his two main
subordinates frank costello and vito
genovese even though lucky named
costello as the acting boss of his
family it was becoming increasingly
clear that genovese covered that
position and that he intended to get it
one way or another according to a
semi-biographical account dictated years
later by luciano himself vito approached
him in private and suggested that lucky
proclaim himself as the boss of bosses
but purely as a symbolic title while
veto himself would actually run the
criminal syndicate back in new york this
is what luciano replied there is no boss
of bosses i turned it down in front of
everybody if i ever change my mind i
will take the title but it won't be up
to you right now you work for me and i
ain't in the mood to retire don't you
ever let me hear this again
or i'll lose my temper after the speech
lucky also met with genebasia in private
just to make it abundantly clear that he
was still the boss apparently vito broke
a few ribs by falling down the stairs
and had to stay behind to recuperate
before returning to new york
the stairs
unfortunately for luciano his own stay
in cuba was cut short once the american
authorities found out that he was there
in february 1947 they demanded that the
cuban government arrest and deport
luciano at first cuba refused but then
the united states stopped all shipment
of legal narcotics to the country until
they complied this was all the
persuasion needed and the cuban police
arrested lucky the very next day and
deported him by the end of the month it
seemed that his plans to continue
serving as the mob boss from cuba had
failed and there had been rumors that it
was actually veto donavezzi who tipped
off the american authorities in the
first place
back in italy luciano was immediately
arrested and spent a few weeks in jail
in palermo before being released he
would be kept under close surveillance
from then but of course this hardly
acted as a deterrent for lucky who
remained involved in the drug trade
often serving as the connection between
the sicilian and american mobs he was
arrested several times in italy but each
time he was released without charges it
seemed that his luck when it came to
avoiding prison sentences had returned
but his freedom to travel was being
increasingly restricted in 1949 he was
labeled a crime threat and banned from
entering rome in 1952 the italian police
took away his passport by 1954 luciano
was not even allowed to leave naples
without permission he had to stay at
home every night he had to check in with
the police once a week and he was barred
from injuring dens of inequity such as
race tracks and liquor stores despite
all of these restrictions luciano was
still described in the press as one of
the chief exponents of the international
underworld and the moving force of all
unlawful traffic especially of narcotics
between italy and the united states the
authorities might have proven powerless
to stop luciano but he also had enemies
on the other side of the law and they
posed a far greater threat specifically
vito genovese whose ambition to become
the new don had never wavered he was
simply biding his time coiled like a
snake waiting for the right opportunity
to strike that opportunity came in 1957
genovese felt confident enough that he
put out a hit on frank costello it
failed as costello was only injured but
costello got the message loud and clear
and he retired enabling veto to take
charge of the family which he renamed
the genovese family after himself as
another sign that lucky was out of the
picture and that it was his show now
meanwhile veto's main ally carlo gambino
also put out a hit on albert anastasia
another boss of one of the five families
this one was more successful and gambino
became the new head of the family which
he renamed after himself while this was
happening there was little that luciano
could do from thousands of miles away
but read about it in the papers costello
and anastasia had been two of his
strongest allies and with them gone his
influence decreased significantly his
one consolation was that genovese only
got to enjoy his position of power for a
couple of years before he was arrested
and imprisoned thus paving the way for
carlo gambino to become the new boss of
the american mafia as far as luciano was
concerned he remained involved in the
business but his role steadily decreased
as time went by he thought about telling
his life story so it could be turned
into a movie but this never panned out
instead all of the notes he dictated
were used for a book which came out a
decade and a half later on january 26
1962 lucky luciano was at the naples
airport waiting for the arrival of a
movie producer when he suffered a heart
attack and died at the age of 64. after
a funeral service in italy his family
obtained permission from the american
government to bring his body and bury it
in new york his impact on american
organized crime might have been greater
than any other person and it is still
evident today
so i really hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]
you